In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for October 2 on which we commemorate the Holy Haramarder
Siprian and Justina the Virgin.
On the second of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Haramarder Siprian and
of the Virgin Martyr, Justina.
One lived at Antioch in the reign of Emperor Desias in the years 249 through 251.
He was rich and of noble birth and enjoyed a great reputation as a philosopher and magician.
Their dwelt in Antioch at that time a maiden of radiant beauty called Justa, whose father,
Odysseus, served as a priest of the idols.
One day she was among those listening to the preaching of the Deacon Prowlius, who had
come to spread the words of everlasting life among the people.
Justa was so struck by what she heard that she straight away believed in Christ with all
her heart.
Justa was the transformation wrought in her by faith and love for God, that her mother
was drawn to join her and went on to convince her husband likewise so that all three asked
Bishop Optatos for holy baptism.
Justa eventually made up her mind to consecrate her virginity to the Lord and to spend the
rest of her life in chastity, fasting and prayer.
A young man called Aglythus, who was a pagan, fell passionately in love with her, but seeing
all his advances rejected, he applied in desperation to Cyprian for magic charms whereby passion
might be given free reign in the body of the pure virgin.
One consulted his books and called up the demons who were always at his command, but
nothing he could do was able to tempt the maiden and let loose in her the fiery darts of lust.
So powerful was her love for her heavenly bridegroom.
Seeing the demons he had sent against her thrice vanquished by the grace of Christ and the
sign of the cross, Cyprian acknowledged that the Christian faith was more powerful than
all his devilish tricks.
He too believed and asked Bishop Anthemos for baptism, renounced his magical arts and publicly
burnt his books.
Later on he himself became Bishop and ordained Justa as a deaconess with the name of
Justina.
During the persecution of Decius they were both arrested and taken to Damascus to be tortured.
They were then brought before the emperor at Nicomedia, where he ordered them to be beheaded.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.